-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight
and now, we're going
to get to the news.
Florida Senator Rick Scott
yesterday criticized Disney
for coming out
against his state's
so-called Don't Say Gay law
and said he won't go back
to the theme park.
Oh, no!
You mean we won't get to see
Rick Scott at Disney World?
[ Laughter ]
Kids, do you even still
want to go?
[ Laughter ]
That's like saying,
the trip's booked,
but heads-up --
The Hall of Presidents
is closed.
[ Laughter and applause ]
After it was announced that
Elon Musk had purchased Twitter,
the social media platform's
co-founder Jack Dorsey
endorsed the sale
and said he trusts Musk's
"mission to extend the light
of consciousness."
Well, I feel a lot better,
knowing that Twitter wasn't
in great hands before.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said yesterday
he tried to congratulate
French President Emanuel Macron
on his reelection,
but was unable to reach him
because Macron was
"at the Eiffel Tower,
having a good time."
[ Laughter ]
Oof!
That's got to hurt.
That's not even a good lie.
[ Laughter ]
[ French accent ]
Uh, President Macron?
He is, uh...
at ze Eiffel Tower?
[ Laughter and applause ]
He is having a good time.
Yeah, he has a baguette.
[ Laughter ]
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy
led a group
of Republicans yesterday
on a visit
to the U.S.-Mexico border,
but Ted Cruz wasn't with them
because he has no interest
in only going halfway to Cancún.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A woman in California recently
survived being stranded
inside her car in the snow
for nearly a week
by eating one yogurt per day.
And, unfortunately
for the rescue team,
it was Activia.
[ Laughter ]
"Whoa!"
"Don't, worry, ma'am we got --
Ohhh!"
[ Laughter ]
How did we want them to react?,
I guess, is a fair question.
Delta Airlines announced today
that its
flight attendants' shifts
will begin during boarding,
instead of after the
plane's doors close,
so if you think boarding
was slow before...
[ Laughter ]
"Alright, we'll now begin
boarding anybody
with a January birthday.
[ Laughter ]
Januarys, you are welcome
to board at this time."
And, finally,
officials in New York
are reportedly considering
allowing pizzerias
and other restaurants
to sell cannabis-infused foods.
"Oh, they only come here
if they're already high,"
said Papa John's.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And that was
a monologue, everybody!